Es geht wild zu in der KI-Welt, und
Google könnte langsam ein riesiges
Comeback feiern. Heute haben wir einige
ziemlich interessante Erkenntnisse, die
darauf hindeuten, dass Google DeepMind
offiziell RSI erreicht hat, was für
rekursive Selbstverbesserung steht. Im
Grunde bedeutet das, dass ein KI-Agent
seine eigenen Fähigkeiten verbessern
kann. Zuverlässige Leaker haben auf
etwas namens RSI-Modell hingewiesen,
einen Checkpoint, der erst gestern
entdeckt wurde. Das wurde innerhalb von
Google Bard X gefunden. Das könnten
mehr als nur Gerüchte sein, denn
Google gibt an, dass Demis Hassabis
seine Aufmerksamkeit auf AGI richtet,
während Berichte nahelegen, dass
Sergey Brin Ressourcen in Richtung RSI
lenkt. Während also alle auf Gemini 4
warten, trainiert Google
möglicherweise hinter den Kulissen den
Trainer. Kommen wir zu Moonshot AI: Der
Gemini K 2.8-Code wurde im Gemini-Code
entdeckt und scheint langsam ausgerollt
zu werden. Die frühen Generationen
wirken vergleichbar mit Kimi K3, aber
mit weitaus effizienterem Denken, was
offensichtlich ein riesiges Upgrade
sein wird, wenn man bedenkt, wie lange
der K3 tatsächlich zum Denken braucht.
Bei OpenAI dachten die Leute, dass GPT-
6 Astra abgeschwächt wurde, nachdem
die Generationen flacher und
synthetischer wirkten. Aber anscheinend
wurde Astra selbst gar nicht
herabgestuft. Die Regression stammte
von veralteten Skill-Dateien und falsch
konfigurierten Inferenz-Engines. OpenAI
hat jedoch zugehört und das Problem
Berichten zufolge innerhalb von etwa 24
bis 36 Stunden behoben, was ziemlich
solide ist. Sie haben am Ende sogar
allen einen Reset gegeben, auch wenn
das nicht jeden betroffen hat. Es gibt
noch viel mehr zu besprechen, also
tauchen wir einfach direkt ein. Es gibt
viele Dinge im KI-Bereich, die ich
nicht wirklich auf dem YouTube-Kanal
veröffentliche, aber ihr könnt über
meinen kostenlosen Newsletter darauf
zugreifen–den Link findet ihr in der
Beschreibung, wo ihr euch völlig
kostenlos anmelden könnt. Beginnen wir
mit Dario, dem CEO von Anthropic, der
ganz unerwartet einen neuen Essay
veröffentlicht hat, in dem er die
KI-Industrie dazu aufruft, die
Entwicklung von Spitzenmodellen zu
verlangsamen. Ich weiß nicht, was
dieser Typ macht oder warum er solche
Sachen überhaupt anspricht. Hier steht
ein kompletter Börsengang bevor und er
schwächt sich im Grunde selbst, indem
er diese Art von Debatte darüber
anheizt, dass KI verlangsamt werden
sollte. Er schlug einen dreiteiligen
Plan vor, wobei Anthropic bereits
zugesagt hat, Drittprüfern auf
Mitarbeiterebene Zugriff auf ein System
zu gewähren, um Sicherheit und
Ausrichtung zu überwachen. Was das
Ganze jedoch interessant macht, ist,
dass Dario gleichzeitig extrem
optimistisch in Bezug auf KI ist,
weshalb ich etwas verwirrt war, da er
irgendwie dem widerspricht, was er zu
implizieren versucht. Er glaubt
außerdem, dass sie die meisten
schweren Krankheiten heilen, das
Wirtschaftswachstum massiv
beschleunigen und innerhalb der
nächsten 5 bis 10 Jahre eine Welt des
Überflusses schaffen könnte. Im
Grunde glaubt Dario also, dass KI die
Menschheit völlig verändern könnte,
meint aber auch, dass wir das Tempo
drosseln müssen. Weiter geht es damit,
dass Google DeepMind RSI überraschend
nahe gekommen sein könnte oder es
vielleicht sogar erreicht hat–für
diejenigen, die es nicht wissen: das
steht für rekursive Selbstverbesserung
. Und wenn an dieser Sache tatsächlich
etwas dran ist, könnte es einer der
größten Umbrüche sein, den wir je in
der KI erlebt haben. Es gab Berichte,
dass Sergey Brin massiv Ressourcen in
die RSI-Forschung lenkt, wobei Leute
ihn als extrem engagiert für RSI und
AGI beschreiben. Auch Demis Hassabis
widmet Berichten zufolge seine volle
Aufmerksamkeit der AGI. Aber das Ganze
wird noch interessanter, wenn man sich
Google ansieht und was sie mit ihren
Modellen gemacht haben. Google hat
davon gesprochen, agentische Schleifen
zu nutzen, die Modelle rekursiv
bewerten und verfeinern. Und DeepMind
hat RSI Berichten zufolge als wichtigen
Teil ihrer gesamten Investitionsthese
bezeichnet. Nun gibt es jemanden namens
Lyra, und im Grunde stammen alle diese
Leaks tatsächlich von ihm. Er verwies
auf die schnelle Veröffentlichung der
kürzlichen Flash-Modelle, die Google
herausgebracht hat, und fragte im
Grunde: „Wie sonst kann Google diese
Modelle so schnell ausliefern und
verbessern?“ Denn wenn man darüber
nachdenkt: Gemini 3.7 und Gemini 3.8
wurden im Grunde in einer Zeitspanne
von nur einem Monat veröffentlicht. Er
stellt im Grunde die Vermutung auf,
dass sie ein internes RSI-Modell haben,
das ihnen hilft, rekursiv über diese
Modelle nachzudenken und sie zu
verbessern, um schneller bessere
Versionen zu veröffentlichen. Er hatte
im Grunde eine Konfiguration namens
RSI-Modell in den internen Backlogs
gefunden, die aufgetaucht war und
erstaunlich gut mit früheren
Kommentaren rund um RSI sowie Live-RL
übereinstimmt. Die Theorie ist, dass
Google ein internes System haben
könnte, bei dem KI hilft, die nächste
KI-Modellgeneration bei Google zu
bewerten, zu trainieren und zu
verbessern. Im Grunde hilft KI dabei,
eine intelligentere KI zu bauen.
Natürlich ist noch nichts bestätigt,
aber diese Leaks, die gerade
aufgetaucht sind, deuten im Grunde
darauf hin, dass Google offiziell RSI
erreicht hat. Google trainiert
vielleicht nicht einfach nur ein
weiteres neues Spitzenmodell. Sie
könnten potenziell den Trainer selbst
trainieren, während alle auf Gemini 4
warten. Und wenn es ihnen gelungen ist,
diesen Feedback-Loop intern deutlich
weiter voranzutreiben, könnte dieses
Gemini 4-Modell einen viel größeren
Sprung bedeuten, als die Leute erwarten
. Die große Frage ist also: Baut
DeepMind im Stillen die Technologie,
die die nächste Generation von
Gemini-Modellen grundlegend anders
macht? Und könnte dies endlich Googles
massives KI-Comeback sein? Ich glaube
wirklich, dass sie sich langsam einem
Comeback nähern, aber wer weiß das
schon. Als Nächstes haben wir die Kimi
K 2.8 Preview, die überraschend in
Kimi Code aufgetaucht ist. Das war
definitiv eine überraschende
Veröffentlichung, da wir nicht
erwartet hatten, dass das Moonshot
AI-Team dieses Modell herausbringt.
Laut Dokumentation bietet Kimi K 2.8
das gleiche Leistungsniveau wie K3,
verfügt aber offenbar über
effizienteres Denken. Es unterstützt
zudem das riesige 1-
Million-Token-Kontextfenster sowie Bild
-und Videoeingaben, zusammen mit
niedrigen, hohen und maximalen
Reasoning-Modi. Und ehrlich gesagt
könnte der effizientere Denkprozess
das größte Upgrade hier sein. Kimi K3
ist, wie wir alle wissen, ein wirklich
großartiges Modell. Es ist eines der
besten Open-Source-Modelle, die es
derzeit gibt. Aber eines der größten
Probleme dieses Modells ist, dass es
bei jeder Anfrage viel zu lange
nachdenkt. Es neigt dazu, bei einfachen
Aufgaben zu lange zu grübeln, was
einer der Gründe ist, warum man es
vielleicht nicht nutzen möchte. Wenn K
2.8 also eine ähnliche Leistung bei
deutlich schnellerem Reasoning liefern
kann, könnte es ein wirklich
nützliches Modell sein. Nutzer mit
einem Kimi-Coding-Abo sehen das Modell
bereits in ihrem Plan erscheinen. Das
Lustige ist jedoch die Namensgebung, da
wir von K3 zurück auf K 2.8 gegangen
sind–das ist vielleicht das erste Mal
, dass ich sehe, wie ein Unternehmen
bei einer neuen Version die Nummer
senkt. Wenn dir dieses Video gefällt
und du den Kanal unterstützen
möchtest, kannst du eine Spende über
die Super Thanks-Option unten in
Erwägung ziehen. Oder du trittst
unserem privaten Discord bei, wo du
monatlich kostenlosen Zugriff auf
verschiedene KI-Tools sowie tägliche
KI-News, exklusive Inhalte und vieles
mehr erhältst. Weiter geht es mit
OpenAI, denn in den letzten Tagen gab
es zahlreiche Berichte, die behaupten,
dass GPT-6 Astra seit dem Start
schlechter geworden ist. Wenn man sich
einige dieser Demos ansieht, versteht
man ehrlich gesagt sofort, warum die
Leute anfangen, Fragen zu stellen. Die
Leute haben die Astra-Version vom Tag
der Veröffentlichung mit der heutigen
Version verglichen, unter Verwendung
derselben Prompts und
Reasoning-Einstellungen. Die
Startversion wirkte merklich
fotorealistischer, schärfer und
stärker bei der Generierung dieser
komplexen 3 D-Szenen. Die neueren
Generationen wirken hingegen flacher,
synthetischer und insgesamt weniger
beeindruckend. Dies führte sofort zu
Spekulationen in der Community, dass
GPT-6 Astra beschnitten wurde, und zur
Frage, warum Frontier-Modell-Labore
ihre Modelle nach der ersten Hype-Phase
immer so stark einschränken. Das ist
jedoch anscheinend nicht passiert.
OpenAI untersuchte diese Berichte von
Nutzern auf X und fand einige
tatsächliche Fehler. Das hängt
tatsächlich mit alten Skills zusammen,
die für ältere Modelle entwickelt
wurden und zu oft auslösten, was Astra
manchmal daran hinderte, die eigene
Arbeit richtig zu überprüfen. Es gab
zudem ein freiwilliges Experiment zur
Kontextverwaltung, das zu vorzeitigen
Stopps oder Antworten auf ältere
Nachrichten führte, wovon laut OpenAI
etwa 4.000 bis 5.000 Nutzer betroffen
waren. Und was wahrscheinlich am
wichtigsten ist: OpenAI entdeckte
fehlerhaft konfigurierte
Inferenz-Engines, die bei einem Teil
des Astra-Datenverkehrs zu einer
messbaren Qualitätsverschlechterung
führten. Diese Probleme wurden
inzwischen behoben oder deaktiviert,
zusammen mit einigen kleineren
Verbesserungen, die Astra konsistenter
machen und die Selbstprüfung
verbessern sollen. Die Berichte, nach
denen Astra schlechter geworden sei,
waren also teilweise wahr, aber für
die meisten Nutzer nicht wirklich
zutreffend. Tatsächlich waren auch nur
5.000 Personen von diesem Fehler
betroffen. Und obwohl nur ein kleiner
Teil der Nutzer betroffen war, hat
OpenAI auf die Community gehört, das
Problem identifiziert und innerhalb von
etwa 24 bis 36 Stunden Korrekturen
bereitgestellt. Aber das ist noch nicht
alles, denn sie haben jedem einzelnen
zahlenden OpenAI-Nutzer einen Reset
gewährt, was unglaublich ist. Denn sie
haben jetzt alle Limits für die
gesamte Woche zurückgesetzt, damit man
Astra noch intensiver nutzen kann. In
Zukunft ist GPT Live 1 offiziell über
die API verfügbar, was ChatGPTs
natürlichere Sprachkonversationen
direkt zu den Entwicklern bringt. Das
große Feature hierbei ist, dass
Sprachassistenten jetzt zuhören
können, während sie sprechen,
ähnlich wie bei Gemini Live. Dadurch
wirken Unterhaltungen wesentlich
natürlicher, anstatt ständig darauf
warten zu müssen, dass die andere
Seite fertig ist. Entwickler können
GPT Live One zudem mit Modellen und
Agenten ihrer Wahl koppeln, was den Weg
für deutlich leistungsfähigere
Echtzeit-Sprachassistenten ebnet. Das
ist ehrlich gesagt ein ziemlich großes
Upgrade für jeden, der KI-Assistenten,
Kundensupport-Bots oder andere
sprachbasierte Anwendungen entwickelt.
Aber das war es auch schon für das
heutige Video über alles, was in der
Welt der KI passiert. Schaut unbedingt
im World of AI Insider Club vorbei. Das
ist unsere School-Community, die wir
kürzlich gestartet haben, und ihr
erhaltet Zugang zu kostenlosen KI-Tools
, zur World of AI Viper
Coding-Plattform sowie zu verschiedenen
Kursen, in denen ich zeige, wie man
diese Agenten optimal einsetzt. Ihr
habt außerdem die Möglichkeit,
frühen Zugriff auf Modelle zu erhalten
, um diese in der Beta-Phase zu testen.
Das ist etwas, bei dem ich mit
verschiedenen Laboren zusammenarbeite,
um euch Zugang zu verschaffen, und ihr
könnt ganz einfach über die Links in
der Videobeschreibung loslegen. Werft
unbedingt auch einen Blick auf die Welt
der KI mit Putting Platform und
Benchmark. Schaut euch den zweiten
Kanal an, abonniert den Newsletter,
tretet dem Discord bei, folgt mir auf
Twitter und abonniert natürlich auch
den Kanal, aktiviert die Glocke, liked
dieses Video und schaut euch unsere
vorherigen Videos an, damit ihr bei den
neuesten KI-Nachrichten auf dem
Laufenden bleibt. Aber mit diesem
Gedanken, Leute, habt einen
fantastischen Tag, bleibt positiv und
wir sehen uns schon bald wieder.
Macht’s gut, Leute.